dude you know i was taken back because i
was like nobody could replace
ellen so i said let me repost this in a
way where people can still see me
having my own talk show but of course
i'm not going to try to replace ellen
well tiff it's so good to see you again
because when i last chatted with you
we were talking about brunch with
tiffany the digital series and now
you're back on tv
but first it's been one hell of a year
so i first want to check in with you
how you holding up let me take my
temperature
i'm doing fine
you know i'm just making the best out of
each day so i'm really excited brunch is
finally on television so
i mean wow who would have thought i mean
and you're back home at vh1 how does
that feel
it feels so good it feels so right and
everybody's so
jealous they just can't quit you
you know they just can't quit you oh
well they they have my heart
right and i mean so many people are so
excited that you're back on tv
especially with this project
what can fans expect from brunch with
tiffany what does that look like
brunch with tiffany what fans can expect
is
just real realism from both sides
like the guests are real you know i'm
bringing the real and we're just
you know stuffing our faces and just
having the greatest time and just
keeping the energy where hey if there's
things going on in life and they want to
discuss it
we're just going to dish it all out on
the table that's it's so easy to get
people
to reveal secrets over drinks and food
isn't that what brunch is all about
though yeah of course
well tell me this because you have so
many amazing guests uh this season on
the show
who was the naughtiest i wanna know who
kept it real real
you know who was the naughtiest and i
could have did something right then and
there
if i wanted to win i would say scrap de
leon
really hey listen i ain't this gonna be
the last time i'm gonna tell you this
okay don't bark up this tree all right i
might have to
okay let me be good all right i'm trying
to tell you and i'm serious
i know you are yes there was a lot going
on
with that interview and a lot of
chemistry
and even people were telling me they
were like are you guys gonna hook up
because they were really feeling the
vibe you know and i had my big old fro
hair on that day
and he was all natural too so it was
just
you know we were creating a real vibe
was there anyone else when you walked
away from
brunch and filming that you're like oh
that felt good i like this person that
you really like connected with
wow i want to say you know who i wanted
more
from and i was like oh let me just sit
back down this ender too quickly
mama d she's a fascinating lady
i mean she just has stories for miles
and miles on end
yeah well one thing we know for sure is
that you got the gift of gab
and this really is like an interview
show and
people have literally been petitioning
you to replace ellen on
her show i mean what was your reaction
to that
well i got super super hyped first of
all because i'm like oh good they could
finally see the vision i want to
you know have my own talk show but then
you know i was taken back because i was
like nobody could replace ellen so i
said
let me repost this in a way where people
can still see me
having my own talk show but of course
i'm not going to try to replace
ellen i love ellen and i think i don't
know if she still is but she was
following me on twitter at one point
okay but what kind of talk show would
you want then would it be something like
ellen would be something a little more
i don't know like i love new york vibes
like what do you envision let's manifest
it right now what's your dream structure
oh my gosh
thank you you're the creative energy i
needed today um
i love what ellen does i think she has a
real heart for the people
and the connection to the audience um i
think
my ideal talk show i would talk to
celebrities
but at the same time i would really want
to connect to the viewers the people at
home
you know be it the moms the dads the
children like everybody in between i
would just have a good time
and you know i would probably cook on
one of the segments okay well just to
keep it true to brunch
right right right right that would just
be a really really good time and it
wouldn't be
patty i think it would just be more just
warm what about like an oprah moment
where you're giving away cars and trips
to australia
[Laughter]
wow okay i like that right now
yeah let's do that
i'll put it out there put it out there
like i mentioned you are back in the vh1
family i mean you've always been the vh1
family and in fact they're re-airing
episodes of i love new york
what is it like for you these days when
you look back and watch those episodes
do you
i definitely i definitely look back and
watch those episodes
and when they play those marathons i
mean it's just like it never went away
they make it feel like
so relevant to today and you know i
would just watch and watch and watch and
i would think oh my goodness
i really had the pick of some really
good men and i was sleeping with most of
them
i really enjoyed you know that era i'm
like wow girl
get it like you really got in there you
know so i see why i'm the hbic it makes
so much sense
forever and always forever and always so
so you're proud you're proud of all of
that right that was an amazing era for
you
oh my goodness i wouldn't change a thing
i'm gonna have to bet on tango
say what as if we couldn't get enough
nostalgia
with tiffany new york pollard uh now
you're reuniting with chance from i love
new york and he's looking for love again
um i saw a little clip where you guys
were smooching what's going on there
oh my goodness you know that
situation i got all set with him and it
just
it took us back to where we used to be
like literally i felt sorry for all the
girls that were there
because our chemistry and our energy it
just it just connected but
i will say this he's down or it was down
to his final two
and he's very much in love with someone
but it was hard to let him go
i bet but you know what yeah you gotta
move forward right you gotta look
uh it's fun to look at the past but i
know that you're always on the go
and looking for love i know you told us
in february that you were in love
so what's the latest what's the update
on tiffany's love life now
i'm still in love okay i i you know
i feel like i'm always just going to
have a heart that goes out to all my i
love new york alumni
yeah so that kid was what it was but
i am so enjoying my man he's a really
good man and he gets my crazy
he gets my [ __ ] he gets all of that
and he's still there
and he loves me without my wig without
my lashes but i will always
it still you're the most beautifulest
woman in the world that's what he gives
so i'm like oh he's a keeper i love that
and do you feel like you can be yourself
with him or do you feel like you found
your i don't know
yourself changing to meet him halfway
i find myself changing and that's
scary i'm not as mean i'm not throwing
dishes anymore
i'm caring about his feelings
and i've never done that with anyone so
it's like wow i really should care about
this person
i curse him out like love him love him
good
that means you are in love love yeah i
think so
i love that let me whip my fans out
exactly i'm like oh i'm happy for you
but
love's a good look on you and speaking
of that i do want to ask you about this
clip you posted
about tamar braxton you guys sometimes
we feel so alone
in these unforsaken times but i just
want to remind you that
you have someone that cares what
compelled you to
post that on your instagram and also to
speak out in support of her
well honestly being in this time right
now
i think none of us could have predicted
this you know we were all posting 2020
vision and we had all these huge
aspirations
so when i heard that she allegedly
attempted to commit suicide i'm like
you know what it's time for me to just
like emerge from my bunker and say
something because it's probably not just
her it's a lot of people that
don't know what to do and what to make
of these days so i just felt like if
there was any light i could shed for not
only her but for anyone else that could
be going through
such emotion to just give whatever it
was that i had on my heart at the time
is though are those struggles something
that you could relate to especially as
uh someone else who you know shares so
much of her life for the cameras
and on reality tv absolutely
um i suffered with panic attacks
and anxiety for so long you know when i
became
famous and people coming up to me in the
market and you know running all over
and like oh my gosh that's new york that
was a lot to deal with
and um i don't think we've had an
especially in the african american
community
we don't pay enough attention to mental
health we're always thought to be very
strong
and to shove it off is it like that with
your community as well
absolutely yeah you survive to survive
yeah we talk our feelings away
so i mean now it's like people are
embracing mental health
and speaking out about the challenges
that we all have
exactly absolutely why do you want to
end on a lighter note what's next for
tiffany pollard
literally the sky is the limit you know
i will say this to put this out there my
clock is ticking
and i want soon but i'm not pregnant yet
but that that may be down the road i
don't know i'm just really paying
attention to
my personal life um of course my career
so you guys can expect to see a lot more
coming from me